ouvert en mai dernier dans le cadre du
plan cancer de poissy la maison les
trois arches accueillait aujourd'hui du
public pour sensibiliser et informer
contre le cancer c'est une maison qui
est dédié aux patients atteints de
cancer et aussi aux proches aux proches
aidants c'est une maison qui propose des
soins de support ce n'est pas une maison
médicale c'est une maison on va dire qui
permet d'avoir des ateliers notamment de
socio-esthétique de l'epic aux logiques
de sophrologie atelier alimentation
aussi réinsertion professionnelle aussi
au programme stands d'informations avec
des psychologues des travailleurs
sociaux des associations ou encore des
diététiciens nouveau trois heures c'est
vrai qu'on parle plutôt de soutien
psychologique c'est vraiment s'il ya une
étape de leur parcours le le patient à
patient 302 faisant vraiment d'échangé
d'avoir s'étend des changes pour eux où
ils se remettent au centre aussi et pas
juste sur un versant de soin médical et
puis l'intérêt aussi de ce dispositif ce
qu'on entend beaucoup par rapport aux
personnes qui fréquentent les trois
heures ch si l'on vit aussi de
rencontrer d'autres personnes c'est un
lieu centralisé où ils peuvent venir où
ils peuvent se sentir en temps de jeu
compris et où ils sont pas forcément
d'avant ils sont pas forcément dans
l'hospitalière l'occasion de rappeler
aussi en pleine campagne octobre rose
l'importance du dépistage du cancer du
sein octobre rose c'est un mois de
sensibilisation pour le dépistage du
cancer du sein l'idée c'est de rappeler
que c'est important de se faire dépister
le plus tôt possible pour essayer de
traiter le mieux possible la maladie on
a beaucoup de d'activité on a eu des
marches on a donc des flash mobs on a
des conférences enfin ya tout un tas
d'activités qui sont là pour rappeler ce
mois qui étreint à moi indispensable au
dépistage du cancer du sein d'autres
actions sont prévues au cours du mois à
poissy dont des stands d'information et
des espaces des changes il 12 21 et 29
octobre prochains